let's go next to Dominic from Texas
Dominic you're on the air
hi David
um I had two questions uh the first one
is what do you think is going to happen
to Fox News once Rupert Murdoch is gone
I don't know you know I read an
interesting long-form piece about six
months ago about how he has multiple
kids I don't remember which ones but
like one of them is very involved with
Fox and one of them wants nothing to do
with it but there's the idea that the
one that's involved might take it in a
different direction but I don't know I
don't have any prediction really I think
it might change I just don't know
exactly how
do you think that they're well I mean I
don't think it will take a rocket
scientist to figure out that there's
still probably going to be spewing the
regular BS but do you think it will get
worse or do you think it will get better
I think it may just evolve in terms of
the feel of it I don't know worse or
better kind of will depend on the
political environment and the cultural
environment around it but you're already
sort of seeing Fox News have to figure
out what space will they occupy because
you know the fake scandals they've been
concocting about Jill and Joe Biden
don't really love each other it's an act
and uh you know just kind of like weird
mask stuff weird vaccine stuff it's not
none of it's really catching that much
and so I think Fox News has already kind
of in a period of self-examination to
figure out what will work and maybe a
change now remember Rupert Murdoch's not
really handling the day-to-day anyway
and so Rupert Murdoch being gone to use
your term it's not clear to me that it
will necessarily change anything because
you you have other people that are
managing the day-to-day
mm-hmm
okay and then my second question is I
know that you've talked about you don't
think that Trump is going to be charged
and I agree with you I don't think he is
either but uh what do you think about
Matt Gates I think that if you give me
an even odds bet just will he be charged
or won't he I'm taking the yes he will
be charged
um but it's not like I feel super strong
about it I think it's like 60 40 that
Gates gets charged
um do you think that he would like lose
his position or anything well there are
rules in the House of Representatives
about that and I believe that if I'd
have to review it but if you're charged
with a felony I think you are
automatically off of committees but I
don't know that you have to resign on
unless you're Pro you're proven guilty
so I don't know about that I'd have to
it would depend on what the charges are
I think
okay yeah
thanks a lot all right my pleasure great
questions uh great to hear from you
let's hear from a few other people let's
go to oh I need to speak to Joshua from
Portugal I have questions Joshua from
Portugal you're on the air
oh Matt is it
it's all right it's an honor to speak
with you it's Pat Matt Pat and David
everybody's here
sorry I was I just didn't think I'd get
called on uh thank you for thank you for
that listen I have a question for you
are you in Portugal
yes I live here okay I have been
following the travel restrictions in
Portugal very closely
I was considering going to the Azores
what I'm trying what I'm trying to
understand is it looks like you can go
to the Azores with a negative test
regardless of what the rules are in
Mainland Portugal is that true or do I
have to wait for the mainland to open
I don't I think this I haven't checked
but I believe the restrictions are
loosening up but I still think you do
need a a negative test if you are yes
you still need a negative test if you're
going to the Azores Islands because it's
an island it's more isolated than the
rest of Portugal but I would be allowed
to go to the Azores you're saying yeah
Beautiful on Just on your say so I'm
going to book a ticket right after the
show
I'm happy can I actually may I ask you a
quick question uh please I'm here at
your service
I thank you
um David I was wondering like I don't
know like sorry is it like do you see
politically wise do you see yourselves
as a Social Democrat uh demosok or a
socialist because I've been I am very
curious on that social Democrats social
Democrats yes which is the northern
European version of capitalism those are
my views oh well it's technically a more
European view of capitalism social
democracy European northern European
okay yes sure
like because
I live in uh you as you I guess I live
in Europe and I
I like get a lot of headaches when
people call me
um a communist from the states despite
the fact that I'm not a communist right
like do you get that a lot as well from
other people
I do I get communist I get socialist I
get Zionist I get authoritarian fascist
I get all of these things I'm just a
Social Democrat that's all I know I know
but I it's just like it's frustrating
when I hear it because it's just not
every American but a lot of Americans
just don't seem to get the difference
between the groups it is you're
completely correct it is frustrating and
Americans don't seem to get it and part
of why they don't get it is they've been
fed lies from Republicans about what it
means to be socialist
yeah but yes it's just the ice and it's
and it it would and they act like and
they always use that insult to me like
the way you just say they say socialist
to me like yeah I don't I could never
understand why they call me that and I
understand that the states it's a slur
there to call someone Associates but to
me you'll just miss I don't I don't like
labels and all that but the way but it
does help but the way to you it's like
it's it's like saying oh you're a
Keynesian and making it an insult rather
than just a description of your economic
beliefs
that's very true and again it gets me
frustrated a lot but I apprec uh sorry I
don't know how to but uh thank you very
much I hope I do hope you enjoy your
trip to the Azores uh David it I've not
been there but they are very beautiful
islands I hope it happens and I so
appreciate the phone call it's been a
perfect phone call
thank you thank you all right I
appreciate it there's Joshua from
Portugal listen if you're holding to
talk to me right now I'm begging you
don't hang up because we're taking a
very quick break it'll feel like almost
nothing if you're holding and then I'm
going right back to the Discord lines
momentarily